this happening in the 10th
arrondissement of the city Rebecca's got
more details for us here in the studio
because it appears now that it may not
just be one location no we understand
this is two separate attacks first of
all we understand according to French
media that our government opened fire in
a bar in Paris in the 11th district we
understand he had an automatic pistol
and according to some reports two people
have now died and seven are wounded who
have looked on Twitter there's several
people are commenting about gun fire
being opened on a number of people lots
of people injured and the second
incident happened at the Stade de France
a football stadium which obviously holds
a number of people we understand that
the French president was there he has
now been evacuated and we understand
there was an explosion there the details
at the moment because this is obviously
just developing have just come in so
obviously in the next few hours we will
get more information but as you say we
understand two are dead and seven have
been wounded according to reports in the
print media yeah French police at the
moment saying no information as to
whether the events are linked but
clearly looking at the geography they
are very close and the timing and the
fact as you say that France Hollande was
in this stadium at the time absolutely
they were hosting a match Germany vs
France and we don't know at the moment
whether this is linked to any sort of
terrorist attack obviously we've seen
incidents in recent months and years in
France where there have been terror
lated incidents yeah the Charlie Hebdo
on the earlier this year yeah but we
don't yet know whether that has any link
to what is going on but we do understand
at the moment these are two separate
attacks and obviously information coming
in at the moment